This is a protein crystal.
It's pretty small, at just
1/10 of a millimetre thick,
but the millions and millions
of protein molecules stacked
inside it are even smaller.
This is Oxfordshire.
It's about 50 kilometres in
diameter, somewhat larger
in comparison.
But it's where scientists
from around the world come
to analyse their tiny
protein crystals.
And that's because it's home to
this, the Diamond Light Source,
a particle accelerator that
can generate beams of light 10
billion times
brighter than the sun.
Compared to our crystals,
the Diamond Light Source
is absolutely gigantic.
It's the most expensive
and sophisticated
scientific facility
ever built in the UK.
The instrument in
this building can
produce x-ray beams
powerful enough
to peer right into the atomic
heart of all kinds of matter.
Diamond is used by scientists
in many different fields,
but nearly half the users
are structural biologists
doing x-ray crystallography.
This is a technique
that allows us
to look at the structure
of any biological molecule
that we can crystallise.
The secret of success
is growing crystals,
which form when
molecules pack together
into highly ordered structures.
This ordering of
the molecules means
that when we fire
x-rays at a crystal,
it diffracts or
scatters the beam
into hundreds of intense rays.
The resulting
diffraction pattern,
detected as an
array of spots, is
dependent on the internal
structure of the crystal.
And by measuring the intensities
and positions of these spots,
we can work back
to the structure
of the molecule it is made from.
It's a method that has
opened our eyes to life
at the molecular level.
X-ray crystallography isn't
a particularly new technique.
In fact, it's been around
for about a century.
In the early days,
crystallographers
used simpler x-ray generators
and photographic plates
like this one to record
their diffraction patterns.
Back then x-ray generators
were much weaker,
and this tended to
limit the technique
to larger crystals,
which could usually only
be grown from smaller and
simpler protein molecules.
Even then, it could take
hours or sometimes days
to record all the
diffraction patterns needed
to solve the crystal
structure of a protein.
But today, with synchrotrons
as powerful as Diamond,
we can use much
smaller crystals,
down to only 5,000th of
a millimetre in size,
which is often what you have
to do if you're trying to study
larger and more
complex proteins.
Here at the core
of the synchrotron
is a particle
accelerator ring that
accelerates electrons to
close to the speed of light.
The ring itself is around
560 metres in circumference,
and dotted around it are
undulators like this one.
Powerful electromagnets
within this pipe
force the electrons to
wiggle from side to side
as they pass through.
And as they wiggle, they
produce an intense pulse
of electromagnetic radiation
in the form of x-rays.
And that pulse of
x-rays shoots straight
into one of the lead-lined
experimental hatches
where visiting
scientists carry out
their diffraction experiments.
During the experiment,
the crystal,
which is mounted on the
end of this little pin,
is cooled by
ultra-cold nitrogen gas
from this nozzle to
help it withstand
the punishing radiation.
This allows us to take much
longer exposures, which
are needed when working
with very small crystals.
The x-rays from
behind emerge here
and are scattered by the crystal
into many different angles.
The diffracted rays are
captured on this detector, which
can record up to
25 images a second,
much faster than the
photographic plates
that we used to use.
So what do we do with
this information?
How do we convert these
diffraction patterns
into molecular structures?
Well I can see my
crystals down a microscope
like this fairly easily.
What I'm doing here
is using lenses
to make a magnified
image of a tiny object.
And that works because the
lens can recombine or focus
the light scattered
from an object
to make an enlarged image.
Because a molecule is much
smaller than the wavelength
of light, I'm never
going to be able to see
it using an
instrument like this.
Instead, we use
x-rays, a form of light
that has a wavelength
about the size of an atom.
But there are no
lenses to focus x-rays.
So we use our
mathematical understanding
of how light scatters to do
the work of the lens for us.
And that allows us to work
backwards from the diffraction
pattern to a
three-dimensional image
of the protein in the crystal.
What we end up with are
three-dimensional maps,
which plot the electron density
of the protein molecule.
And this reveals its branched,
chain-like structure.
The resolution of these maps
is dependent on the quality
of your crystal.
The better they are,
the more accurate
your model is likely to be.
Originally, crystallographers
would painstakingly
build these 3D models by hand.
But now we rely on
computers to generate them.
With good quality data, these
maps are stunningly detailed.
You can see the lumps and bumps
of every atom, every twist
and turn of the protein chain.
Even after you've spent
your time at Diamond
and solved your
protein structure,
you've really only
taken the first step
on a much longer journey towards
understanding how it works.
But from these sorts
of investigations,
we can learn how the biological
molecules of your body
interact with one
another, or how
to design drugs that
will bind to them more
effectively, or even
to design proteins
that nature never got
around to inventing.
Even after 100 years, these
are still exciting times
to be working in
structural biology,
thanks in no small part to
facilities like Diamond.